[Musique]
la première expérience de travail n'a
jamais eu d'autres avant
non et pourtant tu le fait pourquoi tu
fais parce que j'ai besoin de l'argent
parce qu'il est beau et chaud
c'est une occupation ouais c'est un
travail de dépannage ouais bah pour moi
le choix c'est soit par ce travail là où
le vol volley ball est carrément j'ai
pas voulu aller ramasser ce matin tu
peux bien un peu pourquoi
non mais six mois début comme les
avenues de combat les commandes être
filmé ça nous avait il avait un peu un
peu honte quoi parce que nous voir la
télé enfants de ram a fait une bouteille
trouve ça dégradant
maintenant le début ouais est ce que tu
dis là tes copains quel métier tu fais
ouais nan mais maintenant je leur dis
ouais ça ne te gêne pas bah non c'est
quand même mieux que je travaille que je
passe rien le jettera dans la rue
du que
nous resterons le temps on travaille pas
on va voir son entre les deux pays
travaillent pas qui on peut on peut être
amené à voler enfin les comptes
projet départ c'est celui-là c'est à
dire créer des emplois pour des jeunes
qui sont actuellement au chômage et des
jeunes qui ont pas la possibilité
trouver du travail parce qu'ils ont ils
sont sortis de l'école sans diplôme et
ils ont une expérience de vie
professionnelle et c'est pour ça qu'on a
choisi la collecte du verre parce que
c'est un emploi qui demande deux pas de
qualification professionnelle on veut
faire c'est être pas faire le travail
avec les jeunes iront se refuse à être
dans le bureau pendant que son sang sur
le terrain quoi cela peut à travail
privilégié quand même non c'était prévu
dans le sens où il ya pas de rapports
difficiles avec un une hiérarchie pas
trop ah ouais pour ça oui mais le
travail c'est le travail et voulais
travailler dans les circonstances où mon
travail
[Applaudissements]
je
ce poisson je crois que je pourrais m'y
adapter mon travail elle tient patron
plusieurs mois sinon qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on travaille pas
bon au chômage entre
[Musique]
j'en ai un peu marre traders font qu'on
veut je connaissais toutes les rues
demain matin je déconnais encore tous je
préfère sortir un peu plus loin sa
regroupement de l'immeuble
ils ont ils ont nuit là tous les un peu
de toutes les races et on se retrouve en
entre fils d'immigré puisse pas bon puis
quand on regarde dans la rue en quarts
de travail puisque on et frisés mais
quand point c'est tout des maghrébins
j'aurais bien voulu avoir des autres
copains d'un copain de moustique du
travail aussi non non dommage ouais tu
ferais le même boulot que lui non je le
ferai pas pourquoi t'as pas ce qui
m'intéresse pas ça le regarde ça le
regarde
t'es pas d'accord avec lui t'as pas
envie d'essayer de le convaincre
non pas du tout puisqu'il assez grand et
vous le feriez ce boulot là
[Rires]
peut pas ne pas partir comme ça c'est
dur de travailler le temps qu'il trouve
ça dur ouais c'est pas moi c'est pas que
c'est dur mais dont on entend dans la
réalité que pour ça parce que c'est
vraiment c'est dingue
qu'est-ce que d'un petit point explique
un rebelle parce qu'on ya de physique il
ya le moral aussi
oui elle s'étend je trouve que c'est
vraiment do de travailler pour le moral
en plus pour ce qu'on peu de formation
parce que ça te met au pied du mur parce
que ça te parce qu'il faudra des boules
ou assez dur quoi assez dure pas très
propre et puis généralement de fétan
quand on est patron de 40 ans et tout
compte dans leur boîte to convince
ouvriers il faut bosser tout pillon d'un
petit jeune tu vas bosser quand un peu
la banque
mais ici aussi il faut travailler au
missile en vol l'appareil
je crois qu'avant quand il y avait on la
crise du chômage étaient beaucoup moins
forte
les jeunes justement avait la
possibilité de faire plusieurs boîtes de
faire plusieurs boulots et puis un jour
ils trouvaient le boulot qui leur
plaisait et bon il s'arrangeait pour
suivre une formation
alors que maintenant en fait ils sortent
de l'école n'y a rien alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait bas on traîne
c'est rare que tu te retrouves du
travail ce journal est un problème aussi
ce qu'on a une tête frisée pendant la q1
labs voyez que ce travail c'est un droit
pour un jeune est ce qui est un droit de
travail
moi c'est pas un c'est pas un droit
c'est l'obligation moi c'est bon pour
quel jeune oui pour nous par exemple
l'obligation de travailler vu qu'on a
pas de la présentation quoi qu'on a
quitté les de kaunas et où donc une
faute d'argent de sortir pour aller en
boîte pour s'habiller donc il nous faut
de l'argent quoi donner pour les petits
c'est pas bon bah ça le problème
[Musique]
j'étais au chômage qui comprend déjà le
lot de défauts payer la licence il faut
payer les chaussées de boxe tout
alors les loisirs ça compte vraiment
donc on n'y pense plus que le boulou
quoi aussi que l'apprentissage de la vie
c'est pas bon l'enseignement
je trouve que pour des jeunes qui qui
vêle de citer toutes ont des problèmes
familiaux balles et les profits qu'ils
s'en foutent carrément quoi c'est dans
un sens et le portage du boulou quoi on
arrive on fait les matons fait le
français de 4h30 à l'offre on sonne on
rentre chez nous des devoirs et puis
voilà on dort et puis le lendemain c'est
pareil tu as quitté l'école à quel âge
non j'étais 4e en plus mais on va bien
on va bien eu quoi c'est à dire bon ben
on rallonge de passer en troisième
tous ceux qui partaient qu'il a dû
passer une visite médicale moi je n'ai
pas vu donc j'en ai conclu que je triche
à lens 3e et puis je suis pas deux jours
avant la fin d'année avant la fin avant
la fin avant la fin de l'année scolaire
quoi on va vivre tu pars je portais
j'allais pas troisième quoi deux jours
les cds de toute une vie sais c'est dur
[Musique]